[Music]
and welcome back to careful boys where
the boys are careful and the women are
recklessly not present
how dare they well
how dare they all right we got a really
good uh
uh story time here and let's give it up
for it's ryan's uh very very first full
day
he did a practice round
tell us how he did those videos probably
went out thanks for the practice round
hell is a practice with dante bosco of
all people yeah right what's up
that's like the biggest person i could
possibly have next to me he's the
easiest dude ever to [ __ ] talk to
everybody yeah he's bigger than dante
like like size wise he's huge he's like
you're his best you're his best friend
and he's kind of like that lots of good
energy it's a dream
yeah that's great uh yeah so thanks for
letting me host the full day thanks for
doing it i picked the worst articles i
could possibly find good so great
today right now we're to talk about
something really really deep and uh
something with a lot of historically
deep cuts our worst breakups we ever had
the worst breakups
oh man
a lot of my breakups are worse mine's
mine was in high school they're all just
like in a chart they're just all at the
bottom so like in my when i was uh
my
so i did junior year two times you guys
know that this is high school five
why does that make sense for someone how
did that happen all right so we're all
like whoa
by the way
high school i already got kicked out of
like three schools right it's like two
elementary schools
and i'm just a really bad kid i didn't
fit in very well
i got kicked out of my high school
went to a high school out here my cousin
was crushing it i still wasn't doing
good
so like my mom's really proactive she's
like man you gotta get your [ __ ]
together um i found this like military
school maybe that'll be good for you and
it's a boarding school
i was like [ __ ] it i need to get my [ __ ]
together because i keep making the wrong
friends apparently
so i go to
this military school over here since
they have all these like military
traditions you can't come in as a senior
even though i finished my junior year
here so you have to repeat so there's
actually a lot of seniors that are like
19 20 years old
so i go there and i'm like [ __ ] it up
i'm gonna go here but at that time i was
dating this chick that went to
gabrielino high school which is like a
couple cities over and she was crushing
it like debate team cheerleader all that
was post like scholarship to essie and
by interacting with me going to raves
and not coming home for like two weeks
you ruined her life i honestly think i
ruined her life but it was probably the
most fun she's ever had
and when we separated and i went to and
i went to this
life
uh
because we wake up at random strangers
houses you know like [ __ ] passed out
and we're like both 16 17 years old and
there's like 30 year olds around and
[ __ ] anyways um
we i go to this military school
and we have time apart and it kind of
feels like jail because you don't have
cell phone or anything like that and you
have a pay phone and you have pay phone
hour so that's what like fools will go
up and [ __ ] trying to sweet talk or
whatever
you gotta like [ __ ] put in [ __ ]
quarters every single time i'm about to
run out
so i remember i'm like cool after school
i can't wait to go talk to her i'm out
to pay phone [ __ ] twiddling my
[ __ ] fingers and [ __ ] around the
corner yeah and then she told me um
she's been thinking about it and she
wanted to break up and i'm like [ __ ]
i wanted to [ __ ] slam the [ __ ]
paper on two thousand times and i'm like
and that's why i want to break up
right there
and then you get some weekends where you
get to go home oh my god just wait wait
till i come back uh we'll talk about it
and she was like really adamant about it
so i hung up and i remember going back
to my dorm
and that's when the uh
usher um which album was it like eighty
seven or one oh no a7 and i remember
like just listening with with my [ __ ]
uh
cd
you have to hold it straight because if
you go like this a [ __ ] start
yeah i'm [ __ ] sitting there and
i have the top bunk too so my head's all
close to the ceiling i'm all sitting
there there's this one line
he said uh life is a prison when you're
in love alone i was like
you can do you know like if you're back
in the same city i'm going our house
right now what's going on like when
there's like a giant issue and you're
really far away from it it like [ __ ]
magnifies it like crazy
and i was like oh for like [ __ ] three
four days
i'm gonna [ __ ] take ecstasy give me
extra massages man
[Laughter]
heartbreak heartbreak
i'll always remember
that what was her name jessica you
ruined her life
i wonder what she's doing now probably
heroin no it's just
so i i actually uh i ran into her at roy
like maybe like four or five years hey
savoy you ruined your life no no then uh
she got into sc is doing her thing and
so i think she's crushed i think she
like flipped it around because she were
like he's the problem i gotta [ __ ]
get out of this
every time we hang out take all this
ecstasy i don't [ __ ] get my [ __ ]
together
she's dropping e-pills all the time yeah
it was i mean we're like 16 [ __ ]
crossing state lines constantly just
this is crazy so [ __ ] edc dude dude
that's [ __ ] nuts going from like
someone that's like had her [ __ ]
together you know like like the like the
the typical like lead chick you would
see in a high school movie where oh you
know her parents are getting and go to
scholarship and all that dude those kids
are so stressed though are you kidding
me they are they really are too how old
were you i think i was 16 or 17. that's
the biggest [ __ ] breakup era time
like high school yeah yeah that is
because that's when you first get your
uh
sex times
that's where you're the most dramatic i
think my biggest heartbreak was after
like having the sex
because it's like so meaningful and
strong such a big moment at that time in
your life because previous to that you
have heartbreaks but then like you don't
like obsess afterwards i remember it
took me like a [ __ ] almost a year to
get over my my high school girlfriend
that i lost my uh b card to it was so
special yeah like i needed on you
yeah
[Music]
did you have a girlfriend during that
year or no you were just no well i
hooked up but i was always thinking
about her you know and then like i
remember it was so bad bro like well
because she she [ __ ] we she broke up on
the phone with me and she did the whole
like uh it's not you it's me thing
and then i was just like give me some
closure dude just or if it is what is
what i need to improve on so then i i
could get this on my head not not to get
you back but like so so i know like
where i [ __ ] up or like how this
didn't work out for you i couldn't even
[ __ ] get none of that it was like no
no no i'm just like it's me because i'm
i don't deserve you this kind of [ __ ]
that's like when i'm canceling netflix
and they're like oh baby why yeah
just tell us why you're leaving it's
like
not you it's me [ __ ] you
and i'm like what do you mean you know
and then so i was like what 16 or 17
that [ __ ] was like so confusing because
i was like okay if there's nothing wrong
with me and there's something wrong with
her
then why is why is she running away from
me yeah you better get your act together
like yeah what do you need to [ __ ]
work on then and it's all i want to be
friends and i'm like oh so you still
want to talk and talk friendly okay then
i'll call you and then she's like
ignoring me yeah and i'm all like yeah
why why friends don't ignore each
other's that guy hey i'm that guy too
i think we've all been there so i'm like
what what i was it was so confusing
okay gianni
yeah
just appreciate it if she just said like
i'm not feeling this anymore and like
i'm not attracted to you like i i i
don't think we are in love like i want
to split if if i heard those words it
would have been like probably cool
no i would have murdered myself nah it
would have been like
clear but it [ __ ] with my head so much
because i'm like well damn she says she
wants to be friends we're not acting
like friends what did i do wrong i
didn't she didn't say i did anything
wrong because the words don't make sense
so i was so confused it was the first
time you i heard it in my life you know
and then so i'm like 17 year olds and i
think the craziest funniest [ __ ] looking
back was i was in the car full of my
friends we were around her neighborhood
because i had we had a friend that lived
close by right that fool took a wrong
turn and we went close to her house and
i was like no you gotta [ __ ] turn
back bro and he's like why because the
closer i get to our house the [ __ ]
memories come back
to the drama he's like oh [ __ ] he was
the homie too because he was like oh
[ __ ] and then as soon as the car came by
he went skirt and [ __ ] busted a
u-turn and he hightailed out of there
and then i could feel my heart like
chilling the further i got away from her
house
i was like
that's trauma i was like [ __ ] god thank
you thank you
oh that was a close call man too many
memories were coming back dude i
couldn't get close to her anymore like
is that place nearby it's yeah it's
pretty close by all right let's do it
let's see
let's block let's vlog on the field with
joe let's see what happens how's your
heart feeling bud
i know that feeling because uh jessica's
house was close to keppel because i
would drive by all the time she's doing
all the burnouts oh that's the that's
the window i used to jump out of when
her dad came home
too many memories do you go oh this is
when i picked her up at three in the
morning and her mom came chasing her out
and we [ __ ] did burnouts and like
left
to the rave
too many memories it was heartbreaking
started [ __ ] almost the tear went
like this the closer i got to the house
and then when it was like driving away
it [ __ ] sucked back up
it reversed close dude vacuum tears that
was so close today's video is brought to
you by upstart
nothing is more discouraging than paying
toward your credit card but barely
making a dent in your debt that's why
upstart is here to help you pay off your
debt quickly so you can finally get
ahead upside is the fast and easy way to
pay off your debt with a personal loan
all online
whether you're paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment upstart knows
you're more than just your credit score
and is expanding access to affordable
credit unlike other lenders upstart
considers your income and current
employment to get you a smarter rate
with a five-minute rate check you could
see your rate up front for loans from
one thousand up to fifty thousand
dollars wow and receive your loans as
fast as one business day after being
accepted for your loan find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
today by going to upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com off
the record and don't forget to use the
url below so they know that we
sent you guys and loan amounts will be
determined by your credit income and
other certain information that you put
on the loan application that's
upstart.com off the record
dude that's like my story when i was in
high school i think i was like i was 16
i was like a junior or something and
there was this girl in my class didn't
really know her that well she was like
new
and a mutual friend of ours would she
would she would tell me like oh this
girl really likes you and i was like oh
okay all right i had no idea i was like
sounds like nick yeah
okay whatever he's like what do you want
me to do then
that's the reaction
you deflected that even yeah yeah
and then she and then she would continue
to try to like set us up and then
eventually started hanging out and i was
like okay she likes me and then i kind
of started liking her too and all my
knowledge of relationships at this time
i never had a girlfriend before i
haven't had a real first kiss at this
time yet real [ __ ] late bloomer you
know and uh she like she would always
like press everything whatever and we
started hanging out she she and then we
kind of
i kind of
i fell in love with this chick i was i
loved her so much wait that was a fast
jump all right yeah no well you speed it
up but it did happen pretty quick
because like i said everything that i
thought of was from like movies i
thought you had to be like romantic all
the time like super lovey-dovey and i
really liked her and i think i i for
sure scared her away like she probably
thought i was a [ __ ] came out too
strong i came out jump in a tuxedo with
chocolates
just every night hey you know show up at
the horse but like you know we were
[ __ ]
real creepy [ __ ]
no but i really liked it she liked you
and then you came back you reversed it
too strong and she's like ooh i don't
want this i'm pretty sure that's what
happened bro i'm pretty sure
so like throughout this time and we were
hanging out and i thought we were having
a good time or whatever and
like on this is back in my space days
too right wow and i was like in her top
and [ __ ] bro you know what i mean she
had a picture of me and her on her like
myspace and that was dude that's a big
one you made it that's it
i was telling the world about telling
the world bro and i was like wow okay
all right and we're hanging out and then
on aim we're chatting one night her name
is mrs nick mrs nick
she didn't she didn't go full but she
needed to go
too missus
[Laughter]
xoxo but i told her i was like i love
you blah blah blah blah and then she
goes
i don't think we should talk anymore she
hits me with that oh and then my heart
just like sinks on aim on amber my heart
is aiming break up aim breakup dude my
heart's beating so does the sound of
like [ __ ] with you a little bit now that
you do that noise it kind of gives me a
little flashback
a classmate or yeah she was a classmate
she was a classmate how was it
afterwards it was so well you try to
meet up or try to talk on the phone
don't talk to me though she goes i don't
think we should talk anymore i don't
think we should be together like we
shouldn't do this anymore
and i go okay well
like can we still be friends that's what
i said that's so good this is
hey i'm just always trying hey you want
to sit next no okay oh [ __ ] hey yeah
that's me
yeah right oh god
and then tip mode super scent bruh super
simple this is what happens when you
grow up with like send me a picture of a
[ __ ] how do i know it's you
bro i gotta go scan it and then and then
the next day after she hits me with that
i'm like heartbroken and i'm like okay i
gotta try to like get her back whatever
the [ __ ] never happened but i go under
me i go under myspace or whatever and
she already that picture that she had
with me was with another doodle
her aim name became mrs sam i was in the
shower like
i just cried all inside there it was
awesome she's been cheating on you dog
that's savage [ __ ] she's been cheating
we weren't even like together like it
was still like yeah it was for sure i
botched it but thank god i you know i
got that out of where she was talking to
five dudes and then the other guy one
pop probably that was the case
though cause if you had the picture with
her you were in the lead on the
leaderboard for a little bit
maybe like a week or two if you look
down on the top eight maybe you would
have seen your competition he's probably
moving up seven six five yeah
every week she changes the leaderboards
dude it updates on tuesday every week
what's crazy is i thought i thought i'd
when i was first asking this i thought i
had all normal breakups like that were
just like these like that's normal to me
yeah i [ __ ] realized i probably had
the [ __ ] worst one really yes and if
you have one worse than this please
[ __ ] tell it
i was 17
i was with this really beautiful girl
her name was kay
and uh she was uh like way too good for
me
and then um of course as you do when
you're 17 and you're idiot the girl
who's way too good for you [ __ ] find
a way to sabotage it because you believe
it's [ __ ] yours love it um so i start
every day it's like i had a [ __ ]
reason to break up with her because i
was so scared of it like getting ruined
by something else so then i would
manufacture every day like a new [ __ ]
reason like [ __ ] men geniuses you
have to call to be like i'm breaking up
with you yeah your ass is too fat
are
your level's too low for the final boss
but you just see it every day i'm in
disbelief you are just way out of my
league yeah so women in case you're
wondering yeah we [ __ ] do that [ __ ]
um so i did it every day finally i got
the balls to really break up with her
like an idiot and she was totally
devastated at the time she didn't have a
car
so um
she was all frantic trying to find a way
to get to me i was like not picking up
not calling her back from the pager
thing and uh and then she calls her
cousin to give her a ride her cousin on
the way to pick her up to take her to me
dies in a car accident holy
this changes nothing [ __ ]
yeah holy [ __ ]
and she was in the car too no she wasn't
he was going to pick her up to take her
to me as a favor
because i because i was breaking up with
her oh my god and he dies a car accident
and then she like her whole family goes
over to her house
and is like yelling and blaming her
because they found out that's why he was
going to pick her up and they're just
like
they're what kind of [ __ ] faces
you could pick up a cousin
for any reason yeah but i guess like
they just automatically said it was her
fault and then she
in in like the big dramatic fight she's
having with her family tries to kill
herself and she like bashes her head on
the floor
and cracks her skull open and she's in a
coma now and she's in this hospital and
i'm trying to find out which one and her
brother's like i'm not telling you what
hospital she's in i don't want you
visiting her this is your fault too and
she's just keeping it a secret where she
is
and i'm like losing my [ __ ] going holy
crap [ __ ] this all this all happened so
quickly and then uh i couldn't do
anything but wait
um wait so she did a head dive yeah to
try to kill herself the craziest thing
ever during the argument she just she
just went back like out of the stress or
some [ __ ] and then
so she's because there's two major
things happening at once it's [ __ ]
the breakup the
dying and the [ __ ] damn look at what
you caused you [ __ ] bro you're a
[ __ ] domino effect though you're a
butterfly effect of death isn't that
amazing you could just [ __ ] forget
these things happen so yeah she uh so
she's in a coma i don't think she'll
host anymore dude
[Laughter]
she uh after about i forgot if it was
like a few weeks or something i finally
got a hold of her mom
and her mom was like yeah she's out of
the hospital it's it's fine and i was
like well is it okay with you if i see
her i want to come apologize about
everything and her mom's like
uh yeah you can go ahead and see her
she's in england we we've shipped her
out to live there we buried her in
england
why is she living there they you know
when you're bad as an asian you get
[ __ ] moved yeah yeah yeah that's like
me and [ __ ] in the military's
quarters
they moved her to england one step
before abandonment is just banishment
yeah you have like that's your purgatory
so she was living in england
uh working at her family's like hotel or
something which makes her hotter because
she has an accent now that's hot
yeah and i can [ __ ] never stop i
don't remember you ryan i never saw her
again only so [ __ ] mind-blowing that
was one of the craziest stories she
called me she called me like
[ __ ] seven years later she just
called me out of the blue what does she
say they should say [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
son of a [ __ ] no she's doing british
this is really [ __ ] sad but she's
like [ __ ] mental like she's seven
years later she's all [ __ ] weird i
couldn't understand what she was saying
but i knew it was her and she was like
yeah it's me what's up like how you been
like and it was like she couldn't even
[ __ ] process or
project the correct expression for what
you want to say so what you did was you
actually dream come true had a the girl
of your dreams
and then um i think a little bit of joy
right now
a little bit of you yeah
yeah i did was keep turning keep turning
i'm kind of getting
hard off of denying a hot girl
yeah let me keep breaking up with her i
broke up with her so hard that she had
permanent brain damage no dude jesus
yeah and i want this hot ass girl to
keep chasing me how old were you 17.
okay you're forgiven
because i was a minor yeah but i'll
forgive but i won't forget
that's [ __ ] normal your story made me
hurt so hurt that i hate
you yeah
this is joe again
that is a crazy [ __ ] i got nothing
after that bro i will say thank you for
sharing because that is [ __ ] because
i will never share my breakup story but
that is why because that's man that's
some deep [ __ ] that must have [ __ ]
with your heart and mind for a while
like last year i was trying to figure
out how to find her again because i only
have like one connection to her which is
like one of her other cousins and he was
like i have no idea like where she is or
what tried facebook if anybody else told
that story it's a complete [ __ ]
story you know it's right i thought it
was you know what's crazy is like to
this day her
like there's an anagram of her name that
like between me and her and that's still
the password to all my [ __ ]
yeah to this day oh that's kind of weird
as all of it is man i hope you forgive
yourself dude oh i [ __ ] had to if i
[ __ ] forgot it ever happened yeah i
just remembered it like never it's so
crazy
somewhere that is pretty crazy yeah i
mean that's just like because you have
no [ __ ] control over like most of the
disastrous things that happened there
like i didn't have
i wouldn't have a hand in that it's just
like mostly like it just happened to
change yeah it's just like a reflexive
[ __ ] like how did i know that that
would even go down that way yeah did you
look yourself in the mirror and go
yeah what are you gonna do
hey we gonna do it
hey hey you know 17 year olds am i right
tomato tomorrow
that's the best way to cope you know
just channel your inner sabaro
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you